[Musik]
noch immer werden sie viele menschen
religion und wissenschaft ein
unüberbrückbarer gegensatz dabei sagte
der berühmte deutsche physiker max
planck schon in den zwanzigerjahren die
ernsthaften forscher in unserem
materialistisch eingestellten zeit sind
die einzigen tief religiösen menschen
meine beiden gäste sind zwei brüder eine
ist bekannter theologe und buchautor der
andere physiker zusammen haben sie sich
gedanken gemacht über gott und die
quantenphysik ich heiße sie tage
anwenden und sehe mich ja ich bin ganz
herzlich willkommen zu diesem gespräch
gerade an beim grünen sie sind ein
bekannter buchautor benediktiner mönch
sie haben gegen 300 publikationen
geschrieben normalerweise zu themen der
spiritualität über das glück trauer
hoffnung über träume
das buch das sie jetzt zusammen die
ihren bruder michael geschrieben haben
ist aber ein ganz anderes thema über die
quantenphysik wie kam es dazu mein
bruder hat einen vortrag gehalten die
quantenphysik und hat mir den geschickt
und dann habe ich gesagt dass das eine
gute idee dass der gemeinsam ein buch
schreiben weil der vortrag allein war zu
wenig und buch und dass ich da gedanken
dass des theologen dazu schreibe während
meiner gymnasialzeit hatte ich schon mal
auch die idee naturwissenschaftler zu
werden allerdings damals biologie ich
hatte damals ein mikroskop zu
weihnachten schenken lassen und habe da
die partie tierchen untersucht insofern
hat wie das immer interessiert
naturwissenschaft und religion ihr
interesse an naturwissenschaft und
religion nämlich an michael grün das ist
von anfang an auch bei ihnen schon etwas
gewesen das zusammen gegangen ist oder
gab es da eine gewisse spannung
nein also bei mir eigentlich ganz ganz
anders also ich war zunächst für sehr
interessiert und religion an einer
irgendwie ziehung zu gott
und bin eigentlich ein unheimlich
neugierige schüler gewesen habe in der
oberstufe eigentlich alle fächer geliebt
bis auf die physik und englisch sieg
nicht gelebt wie physik nicht geliebt
nein ich denke der hauptgrund war der
lehrer denen ich vier jahre am ende
meiner laufbahn ertragen musste hat er
seine fähigkeiten am besten beschrieben
werden kann mit absoluter unfähigkeit
und trotzdem haben sie dann aber physik
studiert ja das war ein längerer weg
nach dem abitur war ich ein jahr noch im
kloster habe dann aber erkannt dass das
wohl nicht der weg ist der mich zu einem
erfüllten leben bringen wird musste dann
18 monate bundeswehrzeit ableisten
und nachdem ich überhaupt kein geld
hatte war ich gezwungen abend in der
kaserne zu bleiben während alle meine
kameraden in die stadt gegangen sind und
sich vergnügt haben und irgendwann kam
ich dann auf die idee mir in einer
bücherei ein buch zu holen das
atomphysik ist und mit diesem buch ist
im juso so richtig die freude und das
staunen entstanden über das was es
eigentlich in der physik gibt
ich habe dann kurz darauf mir ein buch
von heisenberg geliehen einer der
gründerväter der quantya den ich später
selber noch kennenlernen durfte und die
nicht verehrt habe mein ganzes leben und
das mit gerade mit diesem berner mit
diesem eisenberg da waren meine liebe
wirklich begründet zur physik und sie
hat mich bis heute glaube ich nicht
losgelassen
lassen sie uns noch einen augenblick bei
der frage verweilen wie es dann zu dem
buch gekommen ist die haben sie wurden
angefragt für einen vortrag wo es um das
verhältnis von religion und physik oder
religion quantenphysik in wehr verlangte
dennoch so einem vortrag woher stammte
das interesse ich bin in meiner jetzigen
heimat im pfarrgemeinderat und binder
vorsitzender vom erwachsenen
bildungsausschuss
und wir machen jedes jahr eine
vortragsreihe und da hatten wir mal eine
vortragsreihe da haben wir eigentlich
keinen keinen dritten vortrag mehr
gefunden
wenn er gesagt ich könnte euch selber
meinen vortrag halten
und dann sind sie selber auf die idee
gekommen diese beiden dinge miteinander
zu verbinden
und wie war die reaktion fanden die
leute das sind zwei themen die man
eigentlich nicht miteinander in
verbindung bringen sollte und da gab es
naturwissenschaftler dieses amt haben
bitte keine religion oder gab es
theologen die sagten oh gott jetzt muss
ich mich nicht ganz schwierigen dingen
von denen ich nichts verstehe
auseinandersetzen
im pfarrgemeinderat sind keine
naturwissenschaftler außer mir
die waren alle begeistert werden wir mal
was neues
und als ich dann den vortrag gehalten
habt da war so das echo geteilt viele
viele waren eigentlich sehr angetan
ein paar wenige waren nicht angetan und
haben es mir auch kundgetan
und das waren alles ingenieure oder
physiker aber bei den ingenieur ist klar
die sind in erster linie verhaftet in
der klassischen physik und auch ein
großer teil der physiker hat von der
modernen physik sehr sehr wenig
mitbekommen
also es geht auch hier um umwelt bilder
die es geht im wesentlichen um frage
gestellt ja er stellt ja wie war das
denn bei ihnen anderen können sie haben
zwar gesagt ihr interesse persönlich war
schon von beginn weg dafür die
naturwissenschaftliche forschung aber
jetzt mal als theologe sich noch einmal
auf diese ganz neue weltsicht
einzulassen ist ihnen das schwer
gefallen manchmal schwer gefallen alles
zu verstehen also aber interessiert war
ich auf jeden fall weil für mich war von
anfang an als ich theologie studiert hat
immer die frage wie kann ich die
theologie den menschen vermitteln sehr
lange war für mich der dialog zwischen
theologie und psychologie ganz wichtig
aber ich habe natürlich nie
auch die naturwissenschaft aus dem klick
geburten verloren
zum beispiel die gehirnforschung die hat
mich auch interessiert weil das ja auch
ein thema ist zwischen religion und
naturwissenschaft und auch die
astronomie hat mich interessiert auch
die banden witzig aber ich bin natürlich
kein kein physiker wir haben die schule
auch nicht nur tolle physik gehabt und
trotzdem ich habe verstanden dass mein
bruder geschrieben hat und deswegen
verklagt es lohnt sich da mal weiter zu
arbeiten
jetzt ist eigentlich die verbindung von
religion und quantenphysik im grunde ja
nichts neues bereits in den 80er jahren
gab es publikationen zu diesem thema und
trotzdem habe ich den eindruck die
diskussion an dem beide seiten teilhaben
ist nicht bei uns in der gesellschaft
angekommen wie erklären sie sich dass
warum mussten sie erst heute im jahr
2015 dieses buch schreiben also damals
war der dialog mehr zwischen esoterik
und banden physiker so soll eine
allgemeine spiritualität und die
christliche theologie hat sich zu wenig
damit beschäftige gaben pachinger zum
beispiel augen buch darüber geschrieben
regie aber ein paar theologen haben sich
damit beschäftigt aber die neuesten
theologen für die war das so weit weg
und die hat sich die anstrengungen auf
sich genommen das wirklich zu erforschen
und zu verstehen sondern haben sich
damit begnügt das theologie eine ganz
andere ebene ist das ist immer ganz
bequem dann glaube ich die anderen
wissenschaften nicht zu erforschen also
das ist auf dauer kein guter dinge
jetzt lassen sie uns auf die inhalte der
quantenphysik kommen sie haben ja im
buch auch schön beschrieben wie es zwei
wesentliche theorie in der zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts gibt von der sie sagen das
sind die eckpfeiler der modernen physik
und die haben das weltbild der physiker
erschüttert welche theorien sind das und
was sagen die uns
also wenn wir chronologisch vorgehen die
erste theorie war eigentlich die
quantentheorie allerdings hat die
entwicklung der quantentheorie viel viel
länger gebraucht als die zweite theorie
die zweite war die spezielle
relativitätstheorie zunächst 1905 und
dann die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
dessen den hundertsten geburtstag der
nächste woche feiern dann auch noch
alles ändern dazu kommen ja also die
quantenphysik hat ein fest das
geburtsdatum das ist der 17 dezember
1900 als max planck in einer
ausweglosigkeit einen weg vorgeschlagen
hat man sich dann selber nicht glauben
wollte aber da muss ich vielleicht ein
bisschen ausholen beide theorien sowohl
die relativitätstheorie also die
quantenphysiker sind entstanden
im ringen um die natur des lichtes und
um die eigenschaften des lichtes und da
gab es zwei theorien über die natur des
lichtes die eine theorie lichtes das
sind wellen und die zweite theorie licht
da sind teilchen also teilchen kann man
sich vorstellen so kleine bälle die
ausgesandt werden von einem leuchtend
körper und im jahr 1802 schien der
streit eigentlich eindeutig entschieden
zugunsten der wellen theorie und dann
gab es aber ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts versuche die waren mit
dieser wellen theorie einfach nicht zu
erklären
und da hat sich in seiner not max planck
durchgerungen zu sagen wir könnten
manchmal nicht behandeln sowie teilchen
aber jetzt selber wollte es nicht nicht
richtig wahrhaben
das war eine art tabubruch wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe so eine aussage zu
machen das war ein wirklicher tabubruch
weil es wirklich versuche gehabt die
eindeutige zeit haben licht ist welle
und jetzt plötzlich gibt es versuche die
zeigen liegt ist vielleicht reichen und
beide eigenschaften sind unvereinbar
geglaubt und liegt in den begriff
vielleicht den sie gerade verwendet
haben diese provokation für die
bisherige geltende physik trio ja ja ich
möchte vielleicht leuten welle wenn sie
eine welle ausbreitet ist etwa die
gesamte energie schön gleichmäßig
verteilt über die wellenfront also wenn
sie kugelförmig ist dann ist die ganze
energie schön gleichmäßig verteilt über
diese kugel die sich auf den 9
ja und wenn es teilchen ist dann ist die
gesamte energie konzentriert in einem
winzig kleinen punkt dass man zeichnen
nennt sein riesen unterschied oder bei
der wirkung angenommen ich habe zwei
gleich präparierte teilchen wer für sie
gegen eine wand dann verstärken sie sich
in ihre wirkung
das erste bewirkten einen druck aus das
zweite auch einen druck und dann ist der
druck doppelt so groß als wir nur eins
drauf treffen wäre jetzt licht eine
welle ja dann könnten sich die beiden
gleich gearteten wellen an der wand auch
verstärken aber sie könnten sich
gegenseitig auslöschen
bei einer welle das ist so ein
abwechselndes bild von berg und tal und
wenn es von der einen welle ein berg auf
der wand auf trifft und von der anderen
bälle ein tal
da lässt sich das gegenseitig aus das
hebt sich auf neutral ist ein völlig
anderes verhalten
man kann eigentlich beide charaktere
teilchen und wille nicht verein und was
war jetzt genau dieser revolutionäre
gedanken dahinter was hat denn die
klassischen physiker daran so provoziert
sie waren da an sich das gibt's nicht
es kann nicht etwas zugleich welle und
teilchen sein
das ist die grundlage der quantenphysik
und die andere die allgemein oder die
spezielle relativitätstheorie die sie
angeführt haben die chance die
revolutionäre in unseren wäldern
ausgelöst
die spezielle relativitätstheorie hat
aufgeräumt mit einem ja eine einer
grundlage nicht nur der klassischen
physik sondern auch eine grundlage die
wir menschen alle zu haben scheinen
dass nämlich die zeit etwas absolutes
ist die völlig unabhängig von
gegenständen für alle gleich abläuft und
die spitze jetzt dass sie dass die zeit
kann man gar nicht unabhängig ist von
äußeren umständen sondern wenn sich ein
körper schnell bewegt dann vergeht für
diesen kraft hat die zeit anders und
zwar langsamer als für einen körper der
in ruhe ist
und wenn ich das richtig verstehe dann
war das jetzt diese erschütterung die
bei den klassischen physikern ausging
weil die an eine relativ starke
vorstellung der welt vielleicht auch
hatten ja beschreibt wir anhand von
festen größen und diese festen größen
existieren plötzlich jetzt kennen wir ja
gerade auch aus der theologie dieses
diese provokation die die veränderung
von weltbildern erzeugt sehen sie da
gewisse parallelen
die theologie hat ja lange zeit auch dem
alten weltbild gehuldigt wenn der bibel
oder im mittelalter als galileo und
kepler eine andere
ein anderes bild kommen weltall und für
der sonne und vor der erde hatten dann
hat haben viele theologen dagegen
protestiert weil sie gefangen waren in
ihrem alten weltbild man hat theologie
mit einem weltbild gebunden
und wenn das weltbild sich ändert muss
der theologie auch reagieren sie kann
nicht so tun als ob sie jenseits aller
welt bildet ist das weltbild ist doch
nicht theologie aber es braucht einen
dialog
zwischen theologie wie verstehe ich gott
welches gottesbild habe ich wenn ich
diese naturwissenschaftlichen ergebnisse
ernst nehme und natürlich die klassische
physik die war ja ein stück verschlossen
gegenüber gott alles ist geregelt dass
gott überhaupt keinen platz in der welt
und die moderne quantenphysik ist
zumindestens offen für gott ist doch
kein beweis und gott bewahre kann gott
nicht naturwissenschaftlich beweisen
aber die quantenphysik hat dieses ganze
stadt materielle geöffnet auf den geist
in und lässt zumindestens rom auch für
gut irgendwo meine ich gelesen zu haben
dass die klassische physik die physik
der kräfte die so eine deterministische
variante der physik ist kann man
vielleicht sagen dass dies eine art theo
eine physik der theorie ist während den
die quantenphysik eine physik der
erfahrung ist
ich frage mich jetzt natürlich wo erlebe
ich die quantenphysik in meinem alltag
wird sich spürbar
ich habe vorhin versucht zu erklären was
der ist die die erste aussage der
quantenphysik ist das ist also das
dämlichste doppelcharakter zukommt es
hat sich dann später gezeigt hat 1925
dass diese doppelcharakter nicht nur dem
licht sondern im grunde jeder materie
zukommt und das ist für die physiker
also völlig völlig unverständlich
gewesen aber es haben sich einige
geniale physiker daran gemacht und haben
versucht den doppelcharakter in
mathematische formeln zu prägen
das heißt irak schuldiger und max born
dergleichen und diese mathematik
funktioniert exzellent nur was
dahintersteckt sind diese hinter dieser
mathematik das haben wir erst viel viel
später dann mitbekommen
und da war die erste erkenntnis dass
wenn die mathematik stimmt der zufall
eine ganz wichtige rolle spielt zufall
gibt es in der physik ja
der zufall ist in der natur verankert
sagt diese theorie
das müssen sie jetzt etwas genauer
ausführen was das heißt heißt zum fall
bedeutet eine gewisse sinnlosigkeit eine
gewisse willkür oder oder wie man sich
das im zufalls begriff verstehen
einstein gilt ja auch als mitbegründer
der quantenphysik und als ein stein von
diesem zufall dann erfahren hat wurde ja
der erste gegner der quantenphysik er
wollte an den zufall nicht glauben
er hat gemeint der zufall der in dieser
mathematischen theorie steckt das ist
nur so wie der zufall beim werfen eines
würfels er hat gesagt beim öffnen eines
würfels gibt es tatsächlich keinen
zufall
ich kann nicht voraussagen was am
schluss oben liegt weil ich die
anfangsbedingungen nicht genügend genau
kennen wirst du dich die zb in welche
nike und meine hand hatte in der der
würfel liegt welche augenzahl oben liegt
mit welcher geschwindigkeit ich die hand
nach unten bewegt an es gibt faktoren
die das doch beeinflussen ja sozusagen
nicht zum fall dafür verantwortlich
machen kann das hat sich später gezeigt
dass durch die stimmt dass ich das die
anfangsbedingungen selbst wenn sie exakt
bekannt werden niemals erlauben 100
prozentig vorherzusagen was dann
passiert das zeigt sich ganz extrem in
der mikro physik außer weniger
elementaren baustein etwas besteht umso
deutlicher erkennt man den zufall
ich habe in meinem buch zwei beispiele
druck gebracht
beim radioaktiven zerfall ganz deutlich
den zufall
also wenn ich eine probe habt von nicht
stabilen atomen
dann müssen wir von vielen vielen
tausend von messungen
die sogenannte halbzeit da sagt wie viel
nach dieser halbwertszeit oder dass nach
dieser halbzeit etwa die hälfte davon zu
feiern
ich kann aber niemals von einem
einzelnen atom jetzt sagen dass zerfällt
in der nächsten sekunde oder ist
verfällt nach einem tag oder ist
verfällt nach tausende an oder es
zerfällt niemals das heißt es ist nicht
vorauszusagen nicht voraussehbar wie
geht denn der theologe mit dem begriff
des zufalls und der zufall ist ja auch
ganz nah an der bildschirm sag ich jetzt
mal an der sinnlosigkeit wie versteht
der theologe den begriff des zufalls
gute theologe sagt es gibt keinen zufall
in dem sinn dass es willkürlich ist
darin zufall ist immer auch etwas dass
gott mir schickt also wird bedeutet
natürlich dann theologisch dass es
vielleicht der wille gottes war zu jung
der schweizer psychologe spricht er von
synchronizität das ist auch so etwas
ähnliches ist das manchmal das gleiche
ich träume zum beispiel dass ich den
alten freund treppe und am nächsten tag
gegen die stadt und zufällig treffe ich
ihn deshalb auch kein zufall wurden das
hängt irgendwie zusammen
die regierung kann es auch nicht
erklären warum das zusammenhält
fällt er spricht die rentabilität
psychologisch oder theologisch sagt man
ja gott sieht man den menschen also
theologisch für dich auch nicht sagen
es gibt den reinen zufall ich kann das
nicht vorhersehen aber es fällt dann
zusammen und es hat einen sinn
und insofern ist diese zufalls theorie
der physik durchaus offen für die
spiritualität weil man kann das dann der
speed record erklären und dass es eben
nicht sinnlos ist und nicht willkürlich
sondern dass ein sinn hat dass es jetzt
so geschieht leiden gleich noch etwas
bei dieser sinnfrage
sie widmen einen großen teil in ihrem
buch der kosmologie der frage wie ist
unser universum entstanden ist es einmal
entstanden und sich selbst überlassen
worden oder was passiert heute damit was
wissen wir heute über das universum
wir wissen heute dass das universum
früher viel kleiner war dass es sich aus
den wir kennen die ausbildungs
geschwindigkeit aufgrund der ausdehnung
geschwindigkeit können wir zurück
rechnen dass für etwa 13,8 milliarden
jahren an die substanz die sich im
universum befindet konzentriert war auf
einem winzigen fleck von einem
durchmesser kleiner als von einem
billionstel zentimeter von billionstel
teil eines billionstel zentimeter der
milliardste teil
das ist eine unvorstellbare kleine zahl
ja und wenn wir heute die ausmaße des
universums was macht uns einfach das ist
eine unvorstellbar große da bin ich da
habe ich doch so richtig zusammen
gefasst das ist unvorstellbar jetzt
stellt sich für den physiker die frage
was der sinn dahinter ist so weit ich
verstanden habe gibt diese urknall
theorie dass da anfänglich dieser
unglaublich kleine dieses unglaublich
keine teilchen mit dieser enormen
energie da war die dann sozusagen in
einer plötzlich dynamischen aktion sich
entfaltet als sozusagen gesichert oder
anerkannt stellt sich der physiker
stellt sich der naturwissenschaftler die
sinnfrage dahinter oder ist das aufgabe
der theologie
das ist aufgabe der theologie die
physiker stellen sich die sinnfrage in
der regel nicht als physiker also der
beruf des physikers verbietet fasst
diese sinnfrage denn das gehört in eine
andere kategorie die metaphysik
vor der sich viele physiker fürchten und
trotzdem sagte bereits ein stein auch
dass jeder naturforscher sozusagen per
se eine tiefe religiosität innewohne
meint er mit religiosität etwas anderes
als der theologe von seiner religion
behaupten höhere oder gibt es da
übereinstimmungen
es gibt sicher übereinstimmungen aber
ein stein hat gleich sagen die natur
verdeutlicht also die natur war was
göttliches für ihn hat er kann sich
keinen gott jenseits der natur
vorstellen also es gibt ja verschiedene
theologische aussagen der beziehung
zwischen der welt und gott und das eine
ist der tourismus der das am anfang
gemacht hat und dann einfach den lauf
lässt und das touristische weltbild dass
gott immer der schöpfer ist und bleibt
also nicht nur am anfang waren dann
läuft es wie ein uhrwerk ab sondern gott
gestaltet diese welt und ist in der welt
drin aber nicht nur er geht nicht in der
welt auf das wäre pantheismus sondern
man spricht von patente ist muss dass
gott in allem ist aber gott ist nicht
identisch mit der welt sonne ist auch
etwas außerhalb wir ein anwesender ein
geistiges wesen dass wir letztlich nicht
verstehen können also man kann über gott
nicht
wie wird ein physikalisches dinge
sprechen sondern gott ist jenseits aller
bilderberger wir brauchen solche bilder
von gott wenn sie sagen dass gott
weiterhin als schöpfer gestaltet
widerspricht das nicht der biblischen
auffassung die so ein bild der
abgeschlossenen schöpfung sozusagen
vermittelt also gott schuf die erde als
etwas endlich abgeschlossen ist gut
die biblische geschichte von den sieben
tagen natürlich die mythologische
geschichte die in wunderschönen bildern
das geheimnis der welt auch erklären
will und diese dieser mythos hat nach
wie vor seine bedeutung und seine seine
wahrheit ab es ist keine
naturwissenschaftliche wahrheit und
natürlich ägyptischen hat gottes
geschaffen aber gott wirkt also für die
user theologie wird gott ja immer noch
in der geschichte er ist auch nicht der
der sich verabschiedet hat von der welt
sein
für das judentum und auch für das
christentum ist gott vor allem noch ein
geschichtlicher gott aber auch der
christliche theologie hat immer
verkündet dass gott die kreation
continuo rasen leicht dafür für
unterscheidungskraft geworden dass das
sein überhaupt ist das gott hält das
seien am sein
gott ist das erste mal spricht vom
senden und um sein
gott ist dass das wahre sein dass das
allem seien letztlich sein verleiht
es ist interessant dass sie gerade eben
die diese sechs oder sieben tage
abschnitte erwählt haben in dem die
bibel davon erzählt wie gott die welt
erschaffen hat
im koran finden wir dieselbe aussage
wenn ich jetzt diese aussage als rein
mythologische aussage deuten will dann
komme ich eigentlich als gläubiger
mensch doch in schwierigkeiten können
wir nicht sagen um da vielleicht so ein
bisschen eine gemeinsame ebene zu finden
das die zeit ja relativ ist
und das aus gottes warte die zeit
begriffe andere sind als wiesen heute
verwenden oder wäre das eine falsche
schlussfolgerung nein nein das ist
durchaus eine richtige schlussfolgerung
wir haben verschiedene vorstellungen von
gott aber die meisten vorstellungen sind
doch so wenn es einen gott gibt dann ist
er nicht dann die materie gebunden so
wie wir dann ist er eines geistwesen
und wenn ein reines geistwesen wäre dann
würde fast notgedrungen aus der
relativitätstheorie folgen dann würde
für ihn die zeit etwas völlig anderes
sein als für uns dann würde für ihn im
grunde überhaupt keine zeit verändern
wäre wenn 1000 jahre für ihn eigentlich
völlig zusammenfallen
also hätte er wäre derzeit nicht
unterworfen und für ihn ist zeit einfach
was ganz ganz anderes als für uns das
heißt dann theologisch gesprochen
müssten wir solche sätze wie diese sechs
tage eigentlich noch mal neu überdenken
ja also das sechs tage sind ein bild der
also der bibel steht ja auch ein tag ist
wie tausend jahre und 1000 jahre wie ein
tag wie gott also dieses sicher
relativität gott des jenseits der zeit
und das können wir uns hat wenig
vorstellen wenn wir uns gott vorstellen
da stellen wir sie ganz konkret vor und
auch zeitlich und das ist eben eine
menschliche vorstellung und die
naturwissenschaften physik lehrt auch
dass wir diese menschlichen
vorstellungen etwas erweitern gott wir
brauchen solche vorstellungen von gott
sonst können wir das geht überhaupt
nicht können wir nichts über gott sagen
und die bibel zeigt sind wunderbaren
bildern
ich wäre immer noch gern diese
erschöpfungs geschichte an den sieben
tagen es ist ein wunderbares bild aber
ich denke nicht an sieben tage sondern
das ist einfach ein geheimnis wie die
welt entstanden ist die bibel schreiben
bildern und die natur wirtschaft
versucht es in theorien wobei die
modelle
das weiß man auch sind modelle und so
absolut genau kannst den
naturwissenschaften hoffentlich sagen
die entwickelt die auch wieder
verschiedene modelle theologen merke ich
sind sehr schnell zu sagen da gibt es
geheimnisse bewahren das geheimnis oder
kombi nicht weiter widerspricht da nicht
der physik hat er sagt nein ich will
wissen ich will ergründen ja ein kleines
bisschen widerspricht der physiker schon
obwohl der physiker heute auch zu der
erkenntnis gekommen ist das eine eine
erkenntnis der absoluten wahrheit
unmöglich ist und das heißt das dann
dass man nicht weiter forschen soll oder
dass man gerade erst recht weiter
forschen soll
wir wissen wenn wir weiter forschen
bekommen wir immer wieder in anderen
aspekt der der wahrheit aber es ist uns
auch bewusst und gerade die
quantenphysik hat uns das gelehrt dass
die absolute wahrheit für uns nicht
erkennbar ist erkennen erkennen ist ein
begriff über den wir uns sehr sehr
gründlich gedanken machen müssen wie in
der physik was erkennen wir wir kennen
wir und es gibt viele beispiele die
zeigen dass unsere erkennen abhängig ist
von der von unserer psyche dass unsere
kennen abhängig ist von unseren
messgeräten mit denen wir kennen also
die quantenphysik die sagt soweit ich es
verstanden habe auch aus dass das was
sie beobachten von uns hochgradig
abhängig oder beeinflusst wird ja darf
ich ein bisschen ausholen
da gibt es ein berühmtes beispiel das
nennt sich das netz des fischers von ihr
denken schon gebracht werden
hanspeter thür hat sie ein paar mal in
seinen büchern gebracht und schilderte
ein beispiel ein technologie also ein
fisch kundiger versucht herauszufinden
was ist ein fisch er hatte netz
maschenweite 5 cm umgeht jetzt zum
fischen und am schluss kommt zu der
erkenntnis fisch das ist etwas
lebendiges das im wasser lebt dass
mindestens 5 cm groß ist warum weil die
maschenweite 5 cm ist kann er keine
kleineren fische bekommen
das ist 1
das zeigt das was wir kennen hängt von
unseren messgeräten ab also von dem
gerät das wir benutzen die quantenphysik
geht aber noch noch viel viel tiefer
rein in die erkenntnis die sagt uns
durch die sogenannte eigenschaft der
nicht objektivität
sobald ich versuche etwas genau zu
erkennen
verändere ich es das heißt das was ich
meine zu erkennen dann unterlief ich
eigentlich einer ebenso ja ja das was
ich was ich da erkennen will zeigt sich
mir aufgrund meiner meines
erkenntnisprozess ganz anders als wenn
ich nicht erkennen will
wie können wir dahin in dieser welt
leben wenn wir davon ausgehen dass alles
was wir erkennen eigentlich nicht
wirklich existent ist sondern nur unsere
eigenen betrachtung unterliegt wie
können wir überhaupt dann noch eine
gemeinsame sprache finden über gemeinsam
mit dinge sprechen also hebels die
quantenphysik nicht letztlich alle
unsere vorstellungen der diesseitigen
welt irgendwo aus bringt uns völlig an
die grenzen des vorstellbaren ja da
haben sie recht haben sich recht
einstellen wurde zunächst ein gegner der
quantenphysik wegen des zufalls
später hat er den zufall eigentlich
akzeptiert aber sein hauptproblem war
später die sogenannte nicht objektivität
also die erkenntnis dass die welt ohne
ohne meine erkenntnis vielleicht ganz
anders funktioniert als mit meiner
erkenntnis dass also die absolute
wahrheit sich mir zeit ganz anders als
sie wirklich ist oder nur ein aspekt der
absoluten wahrheit sich mehr zeigt und
wie sich zeigt hängt von von mir ab von
meinen messgeräten von meinem sinne zu
erkennen und das müsste uns eigentlich
dazu bringen vorsichtiger mit unseren
aussagen zu werden
ja aber ich würde nicht sagen dass das
nur illusion ist
gibt ja etwas wie wir sie kennen das ist
hängt von uns ab wie wir da drauf
schauen
das hängt von uns ab aber dieses sein
ist ja also die auch die quantenphysik
nimmt er etwas war nur wie das
wahrnehmen hängt von unseren
voraussetzungen habe und ich denke das
ist schon auch ein wichtiger satz auch
zum beispiel für den dialog der
religionen es gibt nur einen gott die
kriegen sagen gott ist die eigentliche
wahrheit und wahrheit im griechischen
heißt erlebte ja das meint der schleier
der über allem liegt david weggezogen
in der naturwissenschaft und theologie
versuchen wir immer nur einen zipfel zu
ziehen und wahrheit ist nach einer
einfachen durchblicken in der realität
spricht davon erleuchtung dass ich hab
einmal im kopf spielt ist noch nicht
klar
da habe ich auf einmal einen durchblick
das birgt so ich berühre die wahrheit ja
die eigentliche schwierigkeit auf dem
grund allen seins aber das heißt alle
unsere gottesbilder sind natürlich auch
von uns abhängig das wissen wir auch
innerhalb des christentums gibt es
verschiedene große spieler der strafende
gott der kontrollierende gott der
barmherzige gott das hängt immer auch
mit dem selbstbild haben wenn einer der
selbstbestrafung tendenz in sich selber
hat wenn er sich selber ablehnt oder
angst hat vor dem vor der eigenen bezüge
dann braucht es um kontrollieren das
gottesbild und wehr zu setzen dagegen
ein positiveres gottesbilder barmherzige
gott auch das ist noch ein bild gottes
jenseits aller bilder
manche kommen da nicht zurecht wenn der
barmherzige gott dann trotzdem den vater
die mutter sterben lässt dann ja was ist
dann noch mit dem herzigen gott also wo
sich dieses bild auch wieder infrage
stellen
aber das heißt nicht dass ich gott in
frage stelle sondern nur meine bilder
die von gott habe die stäbchen frage
aber gott ist dann ja die eigentliche
wahrheit ich habe immer nur berühren
kann und die quantenphysik berührt sie
auch letztlich die hat auch keine
absolute wahrheit und berühren
die wahrheit hinter allem ist bleiben
wir noch einen moment gleich bei diesen
bildern spüren wir ihnen eine große
offenheit sprechen von von gott wir
sprechen von den gemeinsamen gott und
trotzdem gab es eine stelle im buch da
merkte ich da zieht sich pater anselm
grün ganz wieder auf das christliche
zurück und sagt wir brauchen dieses
personal gottesbild und ein satz der
hängen geblieben ist jesus geht uns alle
unbedingt an das können sie einen muslim
sagen der wir noch dazu ja sagen einem
juden können sie das schon nicht mehr
sagen was sagen sie einem hindu
also warum diese plötzliche rückzug dann
trotzdem wieder auf dieses persönliche
gottesbeziehung gott als person zu
denken natürlich gott als personen
ich sage wir müssen beides sehen im
buddhismus ist der gott mir das personal
und im christentum gibt es auch eine
theologie die einfach sehr gott ist ganz
anders als das wir uns vorstellen
aber bei all dem die spannung
aufrechterhalten gottes persönlich und
über persönlichen persönlich heißt
natürlich nicht dass ich den gott so eng
wie die menschliche person passen
sondern dass dieser gott aber auch mich
anspricht dass ich verantwortung habe
das ist ja auch ein gottesbilder wenn
gott nur dass das göttliche ist dann ist
es ganz nett aber dieses verantwortung
zu übernehmen angesprochen werden zu
sein
das ist glaube ich was wesentlich ist
auch immer alle religionen
also heißt dass damit ich das richtig
verstanden habe dass persönlicher ist
bei ihnen mehr die vorstellung des
gegenübers nicht an die person jesus
gebunden nein jesus gott persönlich ist
jesus ist ein konkretes will ich aber
gesagt theologie ist automatik ist die
kunden geheimnis offen zu halten und das
habe ich ein beispiel jesus gesagt
manche sagen jesus behalten nicht
anderes als ein
religionsgründer und auch die
christliche theologie sagt jesus war
gottes sohn
aber auch da was heißt dass gottes sohn
dann habe ich das eben seit gott da
wissen wir noch lange nicht was es
wirklich bedeutet
sie können nicht meinen gottes sohn ist
ja logisch verstehen sondern ich sage
ganz ehrlich sagt gott ist das was uns
unbedingt angeht
und wenn ich dieses gottes sohn dann
heißt es ich muss mich im stellen
natürlich dass andere religionen sich
das nicht so sehen dass das ist
verständlich
für mich als christen ist jesus einer
der mich unbedingt angeht bin ich nicht
so als geschichtliche gestalt sondern
das interessiert mich aber diese zeit
bedingt sondern seine person die mich
herausfordert und mit der ich ringen
muss und die ich nicht so objektivieren
kann das ist geschichtlich gewesen
das ist alles zeitbedingt nur das ist
interessant wird es über nämlich und das
entweder sie wirken durchaus aber eine
gewisse entwicklung in diesem jesus als
gottessohn oder als göttlicher
göttliches manifest sozusagen eine
gewisse entwicklung da auch in ihrer
theologie damals haben die menschen
jesus als den menschen gesehen dass der
raps den jüdischen gabi der der anders
spricht über gott als die normalen aber
die haben die jünger denn war nicht klar
dass gottessohnes sollen in unserem sinn
das ist einfach eine frage auch dann der
dogmatik wie können wir diesen jesus
verstehen und das war ein langer prozess
innerhalb der kirche auch wie wir diesen
jesus verstehen können und das bleibt
immer noch ein geheimnis hat bei ihnen
michael grün die auseinandersetzung mit
der quantenphysik einen einfluss auf ihr
glaubensverständnis gehabt haben sie
heute anders als sie vielleicht als
junger mann geglaubt haben ja ich glaube
ich schon anders als ich als junger mann
geglaubt habe
meine die quantenphysiker da nicht die
entscheidende rolle gespielt sondern
einfach eine entwicklung eine
menschliche entwicklung und dann auch
eine entwicklung zum
naturwissenschaftler unabhängig von der
quantenphysik auch wenn ich an die
kosmologie denke wenn ich hinter dem
urknall etwa einen schöpfergott sie dann
muss ich doch sagen
dieser gott mustern wie viel großartiger
und unvorstellbarer sein als ich mir in
meiner jugendzeit ist vorstellen konnte
man weiß heute dass oder man weiß
überhaupt dass einer der gründerväter
den sie auch von genannt haben ins tor
einer der gründerväter der quantenphysik
sich auch eingehend mit den vedischen
schriften aus der ähnlichen philosophie
befasst habe und man geht teilweise so
weit dass man auch sagt das hat auch die
grundlage bei ihm gelegt um an diesen
dingen weiter zu denken was ist jetzt
dass er sich die aufgabe der religion
nennen und ich fasse jetzt das wirklich
mal sehr weit also nicht nur die
verschiedenen christlichen auffassungen
sondern wenn wir weit über das
christliche und vielleicht weit über das
monotheistische über die semitischen
religion weit hinaus denken worin sehen
sie da die gemeinsame aufgabe wenn ich
mir etwas kosmologe die welt anschauen
da muss ich eigentlich erschrecken und
was ganz ganz klein werden für diese vor
diesem riesigen weltall in dem der
mensch scheinbar überhaupt keine rolle
spielt und eigentlich muss ich
erschüttert sein wenn ich nur als
physiker das betrachte und muss man da
sein eigentlich als sinnlos ansehen
die religionen glaube ich habe schon
einen ganz wichtigen
sind darin den menschen irgendwie in
diesem unvorstellbaren kosmos einen
hinzuweisen
sein dasein irgendwie zu verachten ihm
trost zu geben die hoffnung zu machen
jetzt weiß man auch dass überhaupt in
den asiatischen philosophien und auch in
den naturwissenschaften beispielsweise
der traditionellen chinesischen medizin
die befunde oder die erkenntnisse der
quantenphysik angewandt werden
gleichzeitig stellen wir aber auch fest
dass es irgendwo an einem punkt dann
vielleicht so fast schon ein bisschen
esoterisch wird wenn dort beispielsweise
von quantenheilung gesprochen wird wann
beginnt bei ihnen anselm grün weil es
ist nicht mehr ganz koscher für sie
waren sagen sie da haben wir jetzt eine
grenze überschritten
gut ich der dialog mit den religionen
finde ich auch heute ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir eben nicht besserwisserisch
sondern jeder hat seine seine sprache
aber wir wissen wir wissen gott des
jenseits aller bilder und ich habe und
punkt geschrieben buddhistischen sen
meisterin und was glaube ich und wenn
wir wenn man dialog führt dann wenn wir
den handel nicht überzeugen sondern der
sitzung und ich saison
das ist wichtig aber die frage wo wir
die grenze überschritten in der esoterik
wird die grenze überschritten dass ich
über gott verfügen möchte gott über die
engel und auch letztlich die
quantenphysik mein bruder sagt jahren
nicht lokalisierbar und eben nicht
vereinnahmen war es ist das zufällige
und über wenn man das alles machen will
alles in der hand hat dann ist eine
grenze überschritten also gott ist der
unverfügbare höher denn wer nicht
verfügen kann nicht kann gott nicht dazu
benutzen um virtuell oder menschlich
noch mich besser zu entwickeln
es gibt ja viele theorien heute die gott
benutzen zum beispiel in amerikanischen
theologie gibt so eine theologie erfolgs
theologie ja also wird nicht genutzt
dass ich mein geld verdiene dass es auch
ein missbrauch von gott
oder wenn gott dazu benutzt wird damit
ich gesünder werde dann darf gott nicht
benutzten gott ist das glaube nach
gesund also der glaube ist kein trick
dass ich keinen keinen arzt mehr brauche
sondern also immer wenn ich das
religiöses absolut setzte das ich dass
ich das manipulieren kann
dann ist die grenze überschritten für
mich wären sie dann auch skeptisch sie
beide skeptisch vielleicht wenn jemand
eine aussage machen würde
die quantenphysik hat mich zum
gottesglauben geführt oder denken sie
nein da gibt es eine offenheit
das wird sich schon akzeptieren also
weil sowie der michael gesagt hat weil
ich das geheimnis
dann werde ich irgendwo offen für gott
der und diese offenheit aber es ist kein
beweis gottes und die quantenphysik
öffnet für gut
sie haben einen weiteren unter vielen
weiteren bemerkenswerten sätzen
geschrieben die mich auch beim aufwachen
lassen
an einer stelle sagen sie physikern
glaubt man mehr als theologen warum die
entwicklung der physik seit etwa dem
sechzehnten jahrhundert bei
außerordentlich erfolgreich hat die
menschen zu einer besseren
lebensbewältigung geholfen war grundlage
für die aufklärung von vieles andere
mehr
und daraus ist die erkenntnis bei vielen
entstanden dass die methoden der
klassischen physik die einzig
wissenschaftlichen methoden sind und
diese methoden die andere wissenschaften
anwenden wie theologie das sind
spekulationen
und das ist keine wissenschaft sprechen
doch auch in der physik von theorien das
heißt etwas gewisse spekulatives daran
auch drin ja oder ist theologie auch nur
eine theorie der theologie ist auch eine
sichtweise wie sehe ich die wirklichkeit
und von der physiker ist auch die
sichtweise
und das ist auch wichtig die theologie
hat auch keine absoluten erhalten
sondern es ist die sichtweise von gott
her dass zu sehen
aber es bleibt immer doch das geheimnis
und die gefahr dass er michael anspricht
waren dass theologen alles besser wissen
wollten und dagegen wehren sich
natürlich zu recht die
naturwissenschaftler und die theologen
brauchen auch eine gewisse
bescheidenheit gerade wenn man die
quantenphysik und die astronomie
studiert dann da haben wir nicht so
selbstsicher daher reden von gott
sondern eben auch dass das geheimnis
gelten lassen und das betroffen seien
von diesen unbegreiflichen darf ich noch
ein bisschen weiter ausführen diese
diese erkenntnis dass die klassische
physik so erfolgreich ist hat leider bei
vielen dazu geführt sich mit der
modernen physik überhaupt nicht
auseinander zu setzen und dieses
bewusstsein der klassischen physik ist
noch in den köpfen in der westlichen
welt fast in fast in allen köpfen
verankert auch bei unserer jugend und
das hat zu einer unheimlichen
gläubigkeit an die physik aber aber an
die klassische physik die die
technologische entwicklung gefördert hat
geführt das heißt sie plädieren für eine
stärkere auseinandersetzung der modernen
physik weil sie weit reichender ich
haben sie damit gute erfahrungen bei
ihren schülern gemacht
das ist natürlich nicht so leicht
schülern schülern in die geheimnisse
etwa der quantenphysik einzuführen
denn die sprache der quantenphysik ist
die mathematik und eine mathematik die
weit über das schulniveau hinausgeht und
wenn ich jetzt meinen schülern das
versuche zu erklären dann muss ich
begriffe verwenden die niemand so ganz
zu treffen
diese erfahrung mussten wir leider
machen in der quantenphysik
dass unsere sprache nicht in der lage
ist das wiederzugeben was die mathematik
aus sagt lassen sich da mal nachfragen
erschien ihr buch war auch ein versuch
eine gemeinsame sprache zwischen
theologie und naturwissenschaft ich sag
jetzt mal zu entwickeln wo stecken wir
da mir scheint manchmal sprechen sie
zwar in der gleichen sprache meinen aber
etwas anderes und manchmal frage ich
mich bei gewissen begriffen wie
beispielsweise der zufall
das sind sie nah beieinander hat
naturwissenschaft physik und theologie
bereits eine gemeinsame sprache
entwickelt oder wo stehen wir
ich glaub nicht dass die gemeinde müsste
halt richtig entwickelt worden ist aber
es gibt zum mindestens von beiden seiten
offenheit ist das haben wir auch
versucht es gibt von der physik die
offenheit für das wasser steigt das
transparente und es gibt in der
theologie zumindest bei manchen die
offenheit ja dass man sich nicht in dem
ghetto sprache zurückziehen kann nicht
rein theologische sondern dass man auch
von gott innerhalb dieser modernen welt
und innerhalb der astronomie und
quantenphysik sprechen muss und das ist
immer neues buch papieren also genau wie
die menschen noch der alten physik
gebettet sind so sind viele theologen
natürlich auch noch der alten theologie
verhaftet weil es bequemer ist da kennen
was ich aus dass andere da muss man
wieder neu suchen wo sehen sie denn
jetzt ansätze wo sie sagen da gibt es
foren oder da gibt es gewisse erkenntnis
darüber oder zumindest ein gemeinsamer
wille dass naturwissenschaft und
theologie oder ich sage jetzt mal
naturwissenschaft und glaube eigentlich
doch eine einheit bilden müssten
ich habe in den letzten jahren schon
also mehrere von ihren vorträgen gehört
die vor allem im kirchlichen bereich
gehalten wurden von teilweise hoch
qualifizierten physikern die auch bereit
waren dann über ihr eigenes gewicht
hinauszugehen und hinaus zu denken
also von daher wird ein kleiner ist ein
kleines bisschen anfang gemacht worden
aber die berührungsangst ist noch immer
viel zu groß und ein ganz wichtiger
grund auch wie gesagt die sprache der
quantenphysik ist die mathematik um
nicht nur der quantenphysik auch die
sprache von großen teilen der physik ist
die mathematik und das ist halt nicht so
leicht das zu verstehen warum lassen
sich dann nachfragen warum heute sind
wir es gewohnt das gehört eigentlich zum
modernen menschen dass er ständig
grenzen überschreiten will warum ziehen
sich hier sowohl naturwissenschaftler
wie auch theologen plötzlich auf ihr
sicheres terrain zurück woher wohin
gründe diese angst die angst ist immer
die angst sich verunsichern zu lassen
an den weltbild und jeder richtet sich
immer gern ein in ein bestimmtes
weltbild dafür dass ich daheim und
sicher und und sich in frage stellen zu
lassen ist nicht einfach aber das gehört
einfach auch der theologie nicht nur
dass ich fragen stelle an gott dann die
wirklichkeit so dass ich mich selber in
frage stellen dass sie dazu braucht es
aber genau der blick von außen oder also
nicht nur in frage wenn beispielsweise
eben die physik mit ihren erkenntnissen
solche fragen an die theologie richtet
wird ihr buch verstehen sie es selber
als ein anfang werden sie da dran
bleiben und das weiterführen diesen
dialog zwischen glaube und vernunft sich
naturwissenschaft und theologie
persönlich oder auch für die
öffentlichkeit
persönlich werde ich mit sicherheit den
dialog weiterführen mit mir selber
ob in der öffentlichkeit weiß ich noch
nicht es gibt anfragen gerade zu hause
von der volkshochschule einen kurs mal
zu halten
das verhältnis zwischen den
naturwissenschaften und der religion
wobei ich ein physiker bin und von
naturwissenschaften
darunter versteht man halt auch anderes
wie die biologie teilweise auch die
medizin und da bin ich zu wenig
kompetent ich weiß es noch nicht ob ich
in einem buch weiter den dialog führen
werde
das war ich eher zu bezweifeln
vielleicht vielleicht zum thema
astronomie das nicht nochmal deshalb
weil nur hier angeschnitten das
natürlich auch das betrifft auch das
gottesbild der großes große weltall und
da gibt es ja auch ständig in der
zeitung neue erkenntnisse aber da wird
der aspekt geäußert der und damit
zusammen hängen sehen da bin ich mein
bruder auch dankbar weil ich weiß auch
nicht wo ich anfangen sollte zu lesen
das ist es gibt so viel und wird im oft
einseitig informiert und das ganze
geheimnis des weltalls mal anzuschauen
dann in richtung theologie dass das wäre
vielleicht aber ob ein buch schreiben
des vorsichtigen kommen wir leben
zurzeit in der physik in einer
spannenden zeit die umwälzungen in
unserer erkenntnisse in den letzten 20
jahren sind sind fast nicht mehr zu
begreifen und ich kann heute als
physiker nicht vorhersagen was wir in
fünf jahren glauben und von daher kann
ich auch nicht sagen wie der dialog
weitergehen wird was ist dabei seine
eine provokation an den bruder der doch
sagt wir wissen doch was wir glauben ja
gut die quantenphysik und religion hat
berührungspunkte aber es ist auch eine
andere ebene
wir glauben an einen gott den schöpfer
und und all das was der dass die politik
versucht hat das geheimnis zu sehen
aber dieser glauben
weil es auch dass wir glauben und die
bilder und die wirklichkeit ist jenseits
aller bilder und insofern würden werden
sie vielleicht manche bilder ändern aber
der glaube decke bleibt aber das
verstehen des glaubens der glaubens
sucht nach einsicht zeigt und kenny
perry und und die einsicht ist immer
auch die erkenntnis der realität und das
verwandelt und so glaubt nicht glaubt
wir wissen was wir glauben trotzdem
wandel sicher glaube wir kommen schon
fast zum schluss ich habe noch eine
große frage
ich habe mir viele große fragen aber ich
lass das jetzt mal weil diese einen in
der physik wie auch in der theologie
bitte begriff der ordnung verwendet aus
der sicht des physikers ist unsere welt
in ordnung oder ist den orten aus dass
sich das physikers ist die welt in
ordnung weil sie den gesetzen gehorcht
und den gesetzen folgt und die gesetze
nicht verletzen kann sprechen von den
naturgesetzen ja sind denn die ewig wird
wir forschen oft ob diese gesetze die
wir heute kennen auch vor 13 milliarden
jahren so gültig waren
und bis jetzt sind wir immer zu der
erkenntnis gekommen ja tatsächlich sie
waren früher auch so und nur das gibt
uns die sicherheit etwa zurück zu
rechnen und wird erkenntnis zu kommen
für 13,8 milliarden jahren da muss wohl
der urknall stattgefunden haben würden
wir zu der erkenntnis kommen dass die
gesetze früher anders waren und in
zukunft anders sein werden
dann müssten wir eigentlich sagen den
grafen zu forschen
nein wir werden niemals genaue aussagen
dann machen können über die
vergangenheit und die zukunft
gut dass wir noch einmal eine
erschütterung ja ja jetzt frage ich
natürlich auch sie ist aus ihrer sicht
als theologe als mönch die welt in
ordnung oder ist in ordnung
die sind in ordnung aber das liegt nicht
an der welt so daran menschen und die
beziehung des menschen zur welt zum
kosmos ist in unordnung getötet sie aus
und der geht nicht achtsam damit um
natürlich die welt wenn wir die
menschenwelt anschaut ist sie auch nicht
in ordnung man brauchte nur die welt
schon ganze angst terror und so weiter
das zeigt dass der viel in ordnung ist
und deswegen ist aber ein dialog immer
wieder wichtigen dialog zwischen den
religionen dass sie sich nicht
gegenseitig bekämpfen sondern gelten
lassen dass wir gemeinsam durch durch
die verschiedenen brillen während
verschiedene brillen wir schon auf das
geheimnis dass auf das was wir schauen
das ist es gehört ein gemeinsam
ich glaube das nehmen wir sehr gerne mit
das geheimnis und die erkenntnis und den
dialog ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei ihnen beiden für dich das gespräch
danke auch sie möchten mehr aufregendes
über physik und metaphysik erfahren
nächste woche in der sternstunde
philosophie ist der einstein spezialist
peter gerissen
stephan klapproth zu gast er erklärt was
es für wissenschaft kunst und
gesellschaft bedeutet dass raum und zeit
keine festen größen mehr sind jetzt
gleich widmet sich aus anlass der
terroranschläge in paris die sternstunde
philosophie der frage sind wir im krieg
zu gast bei meiner kollegin barbara
bleisch ist der deutsche
politikwissenschaftler herfried münkler
einer der weltweit renommiertesten
kriegs forscher bleiben sie dran
[Musik]